people in America are truly desperate
sad I'm crazy and desperate you have
become suggesting that I run for
president you have no idea how bad an
idea that is unbelievably desperate you
have no idea
path that would be number one why would
you wish that big a pay cut on me really
I mean I don't want take a pay cut that
size number two you know Sharon how we
went to a movie last night I would never
get to do that again without like all
this crap going on I can't get you know
I ran I ran six miles this morning I
couldn't do that by myself this morning
nobody was bothering me which is how I
prefer to run for you people that
running herds but I would never be able
to do that again why would I want to do
that why why why and really why would
you want someone like me I mean I'm a
cult leader why would you want me as the
president you're really desperate
that's assets that's how bad the
pickings are out there I'll just tell
you and you know how long it has been
since a bald person has been president
since television was invented we've not
had a bald president since television
was invented elected President Gerald
Ford was appointed there's not been one
and all scholars say there won't be one
again so a full head of hair is a
requirement I can't be President there
it is I'm disqualified right there it
just ends it right there oh my good I
mean we didn't even have any candidates
this year that were bald
did we well I mean Bernie's got bad hey
I mean we got Trump should be bald but I
mean it's just like who knows what's
going on with that stuff but you know I
don't think then we have I don't all the
way at 57 people running on a Republican
ticket and none of them were bald right
Carly Fiorina she has her hair right so
I don't think anybody's bald that I'm
aware of
say I'm just telling you it's in TV
world it
work I mean I'm good on radio but that
TV thing man it puts this this is a face
made for radio you guys are desperate
you're desperate it must be bad out
there what is bad out there use it
definitely is hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show